I do a joke I do a bit in my stand-up
that I say I wish my girlfriend makes me
Bento boxes and now she does so
sometimes you just have to Badger
someone with stand up until they do
something what's up GQ it's Jimmy o Yang
and these are my essentials
[Music]
one of my essentials is this matcha set
I bring it everywhere with me to set at
home anywhere we travel to because I
don't really drink coffee it gets me too
great
I have multiples of these at home when I
travel I take one of my trailer and I
make myself a fresh matcha every morning
it gets a little bit of caffeine but
it's also a nice meditative thing to do
to whisk it I don't drink coffee it gets
me too jittery I feel like I can't get
into my character a lot of times when I
drink coffee and I can't sleep at night
so matcha is an absolute essential for
me and everywhere I go I always ask for
a cup of hot water whether it's from
crafty whatever now I'm like kind of
doing what my mom does like she'll go to
Olive Garden and ask for a glass of hot
water I don't know how older Asian
people especially do it like piping hot
120 degree water just like just chugging
it right just mouth of Steel my temp is
about 80 85 Max I would say
foreign
[Music]
this is one of my favorite Essentials
it's my bentho box set that my
girlfriend got for me she lovingly packs
me a lunch every day because on set with
catering sometimes the food is a little
heavy it's kind of a bit of a crap shoot
so let's see what we have in here oh we
got some crab fried rice here today I
think this is soup the shrimp tom yum
soup I mean come on guys you don't get
this on set this is absolutely essential
to have a good meal that's not too heavy
and it's also portion control because if
there's food in front of me I'm gonna
eat it so if there's a whole catering
portion of food I'm gonna eat all of it
and then after lunch I just would not be
able to perform the bento box is totally
essential
and one of my essentials that I'm
already wearing is this these shoes that
I discovered they're like tiny little
rain boots that doesn't have a whole
boot um they just rubber shoes I love
gardening with them at first me and my
girlfriend both bought a pair and also
we wear the same shoe size so we're very
blessed that we can just interchange our
shoes yeah these are beautiful look at
the color it's by this brand called CVS
we just saw it at a store in Santa
Barbara when we're like in the midst of
wine tasting so this was definitely like
a drunken purchase but it has been the
best pair of shoes so far it's better
than any slides it's like a real pair of
shoes it's comfortable with driving good
for the rain and started what as
gardening shoes and now I just wear it
everywhere even for a GQ interview
and from my emotional support essential
I got this guy my tato potato squeezy
tato look at this it's a stress relief
potato and it's just super cute I think
Japanese thing called tato his name is
t-a-y-t-o-teto so I've been collecting a
lot of different tato things this like
my Hello Kitty is super cute and Squishy
and whenever you know I'm frustrated or
like stressed I just squeeze him a
couple times I think everyone should
have uh their version of a squishy
squeeze a potato look at him he's so
cute I
anything when your name is already
perfect why name you anything his name
is just Tato
beat that
another essential that I take everywhere
with me is this craft gun massage gun I
mean there's many Brands out there
particularly love this because it's a
smaller startup I actually waited like
three months on a Kickstarter to get
this thing it's really cool it switches
and it's really powerful and just after
a tough day
um you know whether it's doing stand up
or in this new show I'm doing I might
have a couple fight scenes for you guys
you gotta get your body right you know
it just feels really good this one has a
good reach you can go behind we also
have a smaller theragon like the baby
travel size one that my girlfriend loves
uh because this one's a little too
intense I honestly it's so powerful I
only have it on the first setting I
never get it on the third setting it
just kind of like too crazy but it's
it's definitely one of my essentials to
keep my body right for the rare times
that I do work out yeah my tightest spot
on my body is my shoulder blade so I
want to make sure I get a gun that's
long enough and it has good enough reach
to hit that ah you see like it's just
like it's like pounding cement it's so
stiff and hard on that part that is
probably doing some spinal damage to me
I'm not sure you know a lot of times
um after I do a Big Show and stand up or
even after I wake up from like a
stressful night I always have to tell
myself to relax my jaws you know like I
feel like I'm always like clenching my
jaw and and I didn't realize how much
stress I had on it so maybe they should
start making one of these that's small
enough just a baby one for your face and
job you know yeah I think they call that
a vibrator
I think everyone should have one of
these in a household it's a PayPal it's
something I grew up with in Hong Kong
it's like a throat coding medicine syrup
it's a lot of herbs in it it's actually
great for voiceovers one of my favorite
actors friends and one of the most
brilliant voiceover actors my friend Ben
Schwartz he's the voice of Sonic the
Hedgehog I've always had this in my
house right but he was the one that told
me to take it before and after voiceover
jobs so the word has gone now outside
the Chinese Community into the voiceover
community and now hopefully to the world
and the Fashion World in GQ tune foreign
cough suppressant and dispersing of
mucus that was actually a commercial in
Hong Kong oh yeah it rhymes
Flonase I need it every day uh just a
couple Spritz inside the nostrils
got me feeling right you know what I
mean I actually used to get a lot of
strep throat a lot of sore throats and I
went to an ear nose and throat doctor
even as an adult when I was like 30
years old like maybe I need my tonsils
out and he was like that's the procedure
I should really avoid how about just try
flonazing for two three months straight
don't skip a day don't only Flonase when
you need it Flonase every day and then
all my sore throats went away and this
is not a commercial for big Pharma this
is just something that works for me we
need medical disclaimers don't don't let
a comedian tell you to use Flonase
interesting I think growing up in Hong
Kong and China allergy wasn't a big
concept and now coming to America I'm
like oh a lot of my ailments were just
allergies you know but I don't know I
don't know which culture is actually
correct because now you have people that
are deathly ill with a flu and they're
just like Oh no just just allergies man
I'm totally cool being at this party so
I don't trust that either
this is one of my essentials what is it
it's a drink it's called
in Mandarin and it's literally a dollar
for this whole pack and if you open it
there's these little packs and then you
can make a little tea it's a little
sweet herbal tea uh it doesn't have any
caffeine or anything I don't think
there's hot and cold you know in Chinese
culture this is more cooling so if you
eat too much fried food too much hot
sauce you want some of this to cool you
down so this is what I do after lunch to
me it's almost like a Chinese Digestive
and it's better than you know drinking
coffee or drinking another tea too much
caffeine after lunch so sometimes I mix
this with a little ginseng and that
gives me the energy but this is just a
nice chill drink you pour in some hot
water and it mixes it it's pretty cool
and I think it's good for you not sure
and to go with my Bento meals it's very
essential to have a good hot sauce I
actually have a collection of hot sauce
in my trailer when I shoot I have some
Italian turoni peppers I have the Lao
ganma the Chinese chili oil and this is
one of my recent favorites it's the
queen Majesty Scotch bonnet Ginger hot
sauce has a really good kick with the
Scotch bonnet but also very
sophisticated and goes well with
everything chicken fish Asian food
American food big favorite I think it
helps my performance to feel like I'm
not at work and I'm at home and I'm
comfortable and I'm in my body right
like it's I guess very actor talk but at
the same time one time I brought this
Trinidadian scorpion sauce to work just
for fun it's delicious and I put on some
chicken that Bree made me and it was so
hot completely ruined my whole face of
makeup I was sweating they have to redo
my hair and makeup for like another 30
minutes so don't do that know your
limits
and another one of my essentials is this
it's a hand sanitizer it looks like a
little credit card it's this brand no
shinku we got in the gifting bag once
and now me and my girlfriend loves it
smells great it almost smells like
perfume this one's actually out how
embarrassing that's how much I use it
but it's like a wallet size hand
sanitizer and you just Spritz it on here
and it just you gotta just trust me it
smells really good I used to use some
hand sanitizer before covet because it's
just easier than washing your hands at
times but ever since covet I have like
an assortment of hand sanitizers in my
house but this is definitely the most
classy coolest and best smelling one
yeah it comes in a lot different scents
this one's called vetiver I also don't
know why I said it in like a French
accent like it's probably just like
vetiver no Shinko if you're listening to
this uh send me some more send me a box
I need this it's kind of expensive I
think oh oh wait a minute it's coming
back to life
perfume it's beautiful big fan thanks GQ
and these are my essentials thank you
for tuning in and
repeat